[Musique]
et maintenant nous allons mettre sur le
grill nous allons mettre sur le ping
motus l'un des jeux d'antenne 2 présenté
par thierry beccaro
motus le quatrième mot teke toc
théo q1 dictée ikea est parfait pour
l'instant rien à dire quatre numéros et
[Musique]
le numéro 50 encore trois autres ayant
bien je suis la ronde 21 spéciales
demain tout va bien nous bon le numéro
10 le numéro 10
dessin et le numéro je me suis dit bien
s'ils veulent revenir demain y'a pas de
problème
alors maintenant j'entends parler de
moto je veux dire mon cher thierry que
cette émission est agréable à regarder
mais que le jeu me paraît compliquer
alors on va faire un challenge voilà en
une minute
je dis bien une minute vous aurez un
prix si vous gagnez vous aurez un livre
de françois xenakis quel prix
s'approprient ce soit un très beau alors
en une minute
on aimerait que vous nous expliquer ce
jeu top c'est parti
c'est très simple vous imaginez petite
gymnastique du cerveau vous avez
toujours mastermind vous aviez cinq
solutions proposées avant de trouver les
vraies couleurs proposées vous pouvez
trouver un mot de cinq lettres
bah voilà déjà plus simple d'accord et
vous avez cinq solutions avant de
retrouver la bonne ok on vous indique si
vous avez lettre vient placer elle est
entourée john et quand elle est à la
bonne place et bien elle est entourée de
rose c'est à dire qu'on vous dit tel est
très bonne mais il faut la replacer
ailleurs telle lettre est valable vous
ne les touchez pas d'accord quand vous
trouvez le mot vous marquer 50 points et
ensuite il ya la partie hasard de ce jeu
savane
alors on prend des petites boules et si
on ne voit pas ce qui se passe vous
prenez une boule noire la main passe à
l'équipe adverse
si vous prenez un numéro eh bien on
efface le lieu où venait de tirer le 25
et bien le jeu là je le jeu hazard c'est
le morpion
il faut aligner une ligne horizontale
verticale ou diagonale comme vous
faisiez à l'école joseph poli est sans
fait motus s'affaissant coin de plus
voilà j'avais perdu mais pas de beaucoup
comme bien des noms mais vous savez
qu'un présentateur de zone général
habitudes de son jeu que c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile d'expliquer comme
ça on va voir maintenant avec olivier
charrière ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs des jeux des gens en
général pas simplement de motus jeu sur
un tel que laisser vous dessinez c'est
gagné
oui et quand pensez vous de ce jeu
superbe l'envi de 10 passes et moi je
trouve ça complètement nue pourquoi non
parce que c'est pas intéressant puis ça
prend la tête c'est pas mal c'est
maurice tic
il ya des artistes c'est assez varié
c'est bien que les c'est motus les
mariés de la deux bon c'est marrant
beaucoup d'humour le principe d'aller
étaler sa vie privée à la télé comme ça
me révulse
motus - motus ah non je connais pas les
chiffres et des lettres assez bien c'est
culturel ça fait marcher le cerveau mais
moi je suis une fille née en france
alors là moi tu ça va ça sans intérêt ça
j'aime bien je la sais ailleurs de faire
partie des jeux intelligents
il faut trouver les mots c'est pas c'est
pas bête quoi ils prennent pas les gens
pour des âmes
qu'attendez vous d'un jeu à la
télévision qu'ils soient marrant ou
alors que qui est un peu d' aventure de
deux sports qui m'apporte des cadeaux ou
quoi
qui enrichissent ma culture par exemple
voilà ça enrichit ma culture alors
françoise elle
c'est ce que pensait téléspectateurs
finalement que les jeux les jeux serbe a
gagné quelques fois des choses
intéressantes pas tellement sur antenne
2 il ya des cadeaux mais sans passion
que comme sur d'autres chaînes
mais ça sert à apprendre des choses oui
je crois que de façon générale les
téléspectateurs attendent des jeux de la
distraction de la détente une certaine
convivialité et pour ceux de ce point de
vue là où tu serais pour tout à fait à
ces critères on en reste bouche cousue
[Musique]
l ady fall et grises l'a dit on en reste
bouche cousue
voilà alors je pense aussi que les gens
ont envie effectivement de d'enrichir
leur culture
et puis l'attrait des gars c'est un
christ est un critère de sélection des
jeux c'est aussi la grosse critique des
téléspectateurs qui n'aime pas les jeux
à la télévision parce qu'il trouve qu'il
ya un côté immoral dans la l'importance
des gains que l'on gagne sur d'autres
sur d'autres chaînes pardon brésilienne
pas parce qu'on donne jamais non mais y
en a qui les hôtes suisses oui je sais
j'ai navigué une critique à formuler
mois par le règlement c'est vrai qu'au
départ et être un petit peu compliqué
mais je crois qu on s'y fait très vite
admire la clé ce kit est ce qui vous
qu'est ce qui vous manque
en instruisant d'améliorer bull ne
servent qu'à faire perdre les candidats
oui c'est ça c'est la partie probabilité
c'est pour ces pour les matheux quoi en
fait
c'est pour ce prénom calculer combien en
at pourcentage mais ça sert à rien de
gagner leur industrie c'est bien ça veut
dire qu'on on saura combien de chances
matt perdre mais c'est tout ce que ça
donne mais les candidats dans les mangas
chaque fois la petite boule qui
évidemment parce que je ne peux pas
gagner voilà non ce serait trop simple
c'est donc si je comprends bien un jeu
tout à fait injuste oui non non non non
il faut dire les choses c'est un jeu
dans lequel il faut avoir quand même
plus de chances qu'eux
dans d'autres non mais les jeux se
divisent toujours en c'est vrai qu'il ya
deux sortes de jeux il ya les jeux de
culture pur il ya des jeux de jeux de
hasard
c'est pareil dans une manière générale
la liste que moi tu salis les deux mais
moi c'est sûr mais je m'arrêterai pas là
dessus moi je joseph
je trouve que continuer à marcher
regarder les autres jeux sur d'autres
chaînes qui sont d'un niveau tout projet
pas regarder sous la table mais qui sont
d'un niveau assez moyen
et regardez motus qui est à un jeu ce
que je crois c'est sympa et ça vous vous
arrêtez pas là dessus
ah oui un message et prenez ambiance
donc les convivialité moi je sais ce que
je portais représentant un jeu monneret
attendait pas présenter un jeune joueur
et j'ai dit rien de challenge il ya
quelque chose à apporter et moi je me
marre à faire sa chasse à tous les
animateurs ça ne marque pas forcément à
présent
[Musique]